johnny
gave me cpr in 1995 when i overdosed
outside the viper room courtney love is
defending johnny depp i don't really
want to
make judgments publicly the singer
shared her two cents in a video posted
over the weekend on social media that's
since been deleted in the vid courtney
praises johnny's character and even
reveals that he once saved her life
johnny
gave me cpr in 1995 when i overdosed
outside the viper room it's not
something you want to visit or
revisit everybody knows somebody that
kind of
has encountered problems with either
illness or drugs or alcohol and
it's not pretty to get into that
yourself
courtney mentions the viper room it's
the west hollywood hot spot that johnny
owned in the 90s
what i wanted out of the viper room i
mean first and foremost
wouldn't it be great to have a place
that you could go to where
you weren't necessarily um on display
all the time or you didn't feel
like a
a novelty you know
you didn't have to sneak in and sneak
out and you know hide and
all that and you could listen to the
music
you know that you and your friends like
but courtney doesn't stop there she
continues her johnny support by sharing
a few examples of how he's been there
for her and her daughter with the late
kurt cobain francis bean
johnny when i was on crack
and francis was having to suffer through
that with all these social workers wrote
her a four-page letter that she's never
showed me on her 13th birthday
and you really know me then he sent um
limos to her school where the social
workers were crawling around
again
unasked
for her and all her friends to go to
both pirates did a bunch of times
courtney goes on to explain how
important the actor's support was when
francis was just a teenager you know she
said to me
when she was 13 mommy he saved my life
and she said it again and he gave her a
trailer i mean
i love you
courtney's public praise for johnny
comes amid his ongoing trial against
ex-wife amber hurt johnny is suing amber
for defamation after she published her
2018 op-ed in the washington post
alleging she suffered domestic abuse
i just saw his arm i could feel his arm
moving
it looked like he was
punching me
but i could just feel this pressure
and courtney well she says she can
relate to the struggles of being at the
center of something so public i've been
the most hated woman in america i've
been the most hated woman in the world
before tick-tock you know and it's a
really
i have a lot of
empathy for what that must feel like for
amber can you imagine being her jesus
ultimately the whole front woman makes
it clear she wants things to shake out
fairly if you use
a movement
for your own personal gain and you
inhabit queer feminist intersectional
spaces
and you abuse that moment
um
then
you know you
i hope i hope justice gets served
whatever it is and i think we should
have less shot and proud and more
empathy for all concerned but after the
video went viral courtney posted again
saying she doesn't want her defensive
johnny to be seen as a takedown of amber
quote i want to show neutral support for
a friend i don't want to bully adding
that she hopes everyone shows sincere
empathy for both parties
[Music]
you